Russia says thousands of reservists have
answered the call to fight in Ukraine
While others have been fleeing the
country or staying and protesting
against Vladimir Putin's mobilization
order as Moscow bolsters its war effort
Russian installed officials are holding
so-called referendums that would lay the
groundwork for Russia to Annex four
occupied regions of Ukraine Ukrainian
officials and Witnesses say that
residents are being coerced into taking
part often at gunpoint at the U.N
General Assembly Russian foreign
minister Sergey lavrov said the four
regions will be under Russia's full
protection if they are annexed by Moscow
as Moscow swiftly draws new recruits to
bolster struggling military campaign in
Ukraine Russians again took to the
streets to denounce the mobilization
order from Saint Petersburg to Siberia
they chanted no to war and Putin to the
trenches
police detained more than one thousand
protesters in dozens of cities across
the country
in Moscow one protester turned up in a
wheelchair holding a sign saying do you
want to be like me she wasn't arrested
but police quickly took away her sign
foreign
this video released by Russia's defense
Ministry purportedly shows newly
recruited Russian reservists being
issued weapons before heading off for
combat training thousands have been
called up to serve in Russia's War
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
has a message for the draftees
voluntarily surrender and you will not
be mistreated the circumstances of Your
Surrender will remain secret and if you
don't want to return to Russia you don't
have to he made the promise during his
nightly address switching to Russian to
deliver his message
not accepting a draft notice is better
than dying a war criminal on foreign
land running from this criminal
mobilization is better than being
crippled and then answering in court for
participating in this aggression on top
of it that's surrendering to Ukrainian
captivity is better than falling under
the strikes of our weapons entirely just
strikes because Ukraine is defending
itself in this war
Vladimir Putin signed a decree
toughening sentences for those who do
voluntarily Surrender by up to 10 years
in prison desertion and refusal to fight
carry similar penalties
for more we can speak to our
correspondent Emmanuel Chez who's
standing by for us and Kiev hello to you
Emma so how did lavrov's latest
statement go down in Ukraine
well like any or any other of his
statements go down Ukraine will not
change its stance it will not be
impressed also by statements coming from
the Russian side last night Ukrainian
President Vladimir zedeschi addressed
Russians directly in Russian he does
that often when he wants to pass a clear
message directly to the Russian
population he called Four soldiers
conscripts joining the Russian army now
to not fight against Ukraine to
surrender at the first opportunity and
he says that no matter what happens with
that Mobility mobilization Ukraine will
prevail that's also the feeling that we
get when talking to the population for
them it doesn't change much you know
here on the ground in back in February
expats were not very optimistic as to
how long the Ukrainian Army could hold
on against the Russian one yet we're
over seven months into that war and they
managed resist quite well so far
and Emma what have you been hearing
about these so-called referendums that
are underway in the occupied territories
in eastern Ukraine
it's uh it's the same it's a spirit of
resistance here in in Ukraine from the
Ukrainian side people living in those
occupied territory report that those
sham referendums are being held
sometimes at gunpoint so you have armed
Russian officers or proxies coming to
houses trying to force people to vote so
this will not be recognized by the
International Community nor will it be
recognized by Ukraine and we have to
keep in mind that you know there's a
vast amount of population in those
regions who fled this so as not to live
under Russian occupation
that was DW's correspondent and Manuel
Chez and Kiev Emmanuel thank you so much